Speaker 1: another legal problem for Donald
Trump that I want to briefly talk about and
then we're going to move on to other things. A
federal judge has found that Donald Trump lied
under oath about voter fraud in Georgia while
trying to overturn the 2020 election results.
Now we're switching gears. Before we were talking
about the federal investigation that is connected
to the search warrant at Mar a Lago. That's
the last story. This is a different situation
now. Business Insider summarizes the statement
by the judge. A federal judge Wednesday said
Trump lied under oath about voter fraud claims in
the 2020 election. Not a big shock. Trump, quote,
knew that the specific numbers of voter fraud were
wrong, but touted them both in court and to the
public. This is per Judge David Carter. Carter
made the determination in a ruling ordering a
Republican lawyer to turn over his communications
to the January 6th committee. This goes back
to December 4th of 2020. And I know many of you
remember this. Many of you don't. Many of you have
chosen to forget it. And I understand I understand
why. On December 4th, 2020, Trump's legal team
filed a lawsuit in Georgia State Court alleging
that Fulton County miscounted thousands of votes.
They also contested the state courts proceedings
in federal court. This was one of dozens of
complaints that Trump and lawyers filed in various
courts. Later that month, Carter wrote in his
ruling Eastman This is Trump's lawyer. Eastman
said in an email that although Trump had, quote,
signed a verification for the state court filing
on December one, he had since been made aware that
some of the allegations and evidence proffered
by the experts has been inaccurate. For him to
sign a new certification with that knowledge and
incorporation by reference would not be accurate,
he added. The emails show that Trump knew that
the specific numbers of voter fraud were wrong,
but continued to tout those numbers both in court
and to the public. This is also not the first time
that this has been suggested. So it's abundantly
clear that in every single one of these cases, you
have claims that are made that normal people who
look at data and evidence doubt. We ask ourselves,
are they making these claims out of ignorance
or are they making these claims knowing they
are false claims in order to deceive others? And
we don't necessarily know right away. But then,
slowly but surely, we come to learn that these
claims are made knowing that they are lying
in the Mar a Lago DOJ situation. Did Trump
believe that they really had given back all
the documents? I don't know. Maybe we later find
out. Trump knew they had not given back all the
documents because there is a report that he had
an employee move documents at Mar a Lago. Oh,
okay. So he was lying. He was lying deliberately
to deceive. Arguably an obstructive act.
Same thing here. Okay. At the beginning of
December, Trump signs off on We believe these
are the numbers of fraudulent, phony, invalid
votes from Georgia. Maybe Trump believed it at
that point in time. We then get testimony and
statements under oath that actually later on,
when Trump continued to sign off on this stuff,
Trump had been advised that what he was claiming
and signing off on was not actually the truth.
Unfortunately, Georgia State Law says that the
punishment here is up to one year in jail and up
to a $1,000 fine or both. This is 2020 Georgia
Code. Title 16 Crimes and Offenses. Chapter ten
Offenses Against Public Administration. Article
four Perjury and Related Offenses. And it says,
Punished by a fine of not more than $1,000 or by
imprisonment, not less than one, not more than
ten years or both. But the particulars of this
likely point to no more than one year in prison,
one year in jail, rather. You know, there is this
question is whether as to whether the American
justice system should really assess fines as a
function of income, because one of the realities
that we have in the justice system in the United
States with such drastically different financial
circumstances for people are that the same $5,000
fine can be a completely unpayable bankruptcy
inducing fine for many in society, and then such
an insignificant fine for others in society
that it does nothing whatsoever to actually
punish a bad act. And so there are countries that
do this with speeding tickets, for example. We've
talked about it before. I believe Norway might
be one of those countries, but I don't remember
completely offhand. But there is a real question
as to whether fines should be assessed based on
ability to pay with some upper and lower
limit. Certainly, I think that reasonable
people could agree to that. So not a particularly
auspicious day yesterday for Donald Trump from a
legal standpoint, but when we continue to ask
the question, well, but then so what? What's
coming? Is anything coming? I think we all are
in the position of saying we don't really know.